welcome back amber hi mark how are you
i'm amazing
you you are amazing so wonderful tell me
what's going on in your life
well lately um we just buried my
grandmother mary rock oh i'm sorry
she died from the kovic
and um her favorite son
gave it to her
my uncle anthony
gave her kovic
and it killed her how was she she was
84.
84 is a good ride though yes she she did
all she she did all she could for all
her grandkids
she was an awesome woman she was amazing
she was she was who kept the family
together yeah
yeah i'm sorry about that that's okay
i'll be sorry she's in heaven now
she got her wings
she was born in 1939.
and what's going on in your life in my
life now um i'm trying to get it
together i'm taking it one day at a time
taking it one day at a time i'm getting
more involved with my kids
so um so
after your first video a lot of people
were
upset that you they're worried about
your daughter who's staying with and
i've seen her we've been we've been in
contact with each other now um what
happened was she didn't nothing's
happening with her father you know he's
taking good care of her but um
however he needs to keep her around her
family more i would love him to
put her with her family more you know
sammy um
uh she hasn't been touched by him but
she has been touched
um
she was raped
so i found out she was sexually active
and i went to her immediately to find
out what was going on how old is she
she's 14 14
yes so who who got at her uh one of her
friend her she went to spend the night
at a friend's house and the friend's
older brother did it and she stays in
malibu she stays in malibu so this
happened in malibu no this happened at
one of her friend's house
which is where i don't know
oh i don't know what which friend it was
or where they live but i know that it
happened
and my thing was
i wanted to educate her about sex since
she's had it
as a parent that's what i'm supposed to
do
and that's what i did do
nobody's perfect
she's not perfect and i'm not perfect so
we strive to be
i'm sorry about that too
she was right
how does that make you feel makes me
feel awful i told her i said baby it's
because mama wasn't there for you right
she said she didn't even look at me she
just looked the other way
she just looked oh wait
i said what's his name
you tell me his name
i want to make sure it's not none of my
friends sons
period
anyway
my job is as a parent was to
to
tell her you know that it wasn't her
fault
and
and it was going it happened and
it was something that i could have
prevented by not letting her go spend
the night at her friend's house
she should not be allowed to go spend
the night nowhere
period
but i can't control that because
her dad has physical custody of her and
he got that
um
he lied to the court okay and told them
that he served me with papers that's how
he got her i didn't give my daughter to
him
i he
he lied to them and said that he served
me with papers and he never served me
with a paper at all so she's staying
with her biological father he she
staying with
her presumed father you understand what
i'm saying and the judge said that you
don't have to be a logical parent to be
a parent so
that's what the judge said does he think
he's her biological father he knows he's
not her biological father
he knows that and he still
he takes care of her he does a good job
yes he does all right job he's not doing
the best but he's a man you can't raise
a woman
a man can't raise a woman
he takes a woman to where he's a woman
and um i've been in her life and i'm
i've been involved i'm doing my part can
a woman raise a young man
a woman can raise a man probably
uh to her best ability
she can't teach him everything
she can't teach him how to be a man
no
we do our best
tell me about the casitas oh the casitas
are you still going back i've been going
there but i've been trying to stay off
lay off the see i only go there now to
it it jogs my brain for for my book that
i'm writing
so the casitas are underground gambling
for those who don't know yeah it is and
what it's doing for me it stimulates my
brain
it gives me ideas
you know it
it helps me
with my book
that i'm writing you're writing a book
it's about your life about my life
so i'm not the best at writing it so i'm
going to need some help from someone
that's probably therapeutic as well it
is very therapeutic for me
the casitas was therapeutic
but they are they were they were there
for me when no one else would what tell
me what the uh the benefits of going to
a underground gambling spot
are the benefits are
that
you don't have to have id
um you can gamble the adrenaline the
adrenaline and and
it's the same as a regular casino
yeah yeah i think you have drugs and you
have prostitutes as well
um there's all that infant there yeah
everything that's bad is in there that's
what i'm saying
everything that's bad is in there but
you need a little bad in your life
sometimes you need a little mixed bag
with the good
to balance things out yeah yeah that's
like that that's how i stay balanced
yeah
it's funny i think you're right
you can't be goody two shoes all the
time oh not all the time no one's
perfect
okay not even me
i'm trying to be the best me that i can
be
okay
um
my first interview
i said a lot about my mother and how she
was controlling but although she was
controlling she raised some damn good
kids
okay
my sister has two businesses
and
she was like the chat you know she was
she had learning disabilities stuff so
we can all overcome our obstacles
any obstacle anything you can overcome
it
i'm not saying i'm clean and i'm off for
drugs but i'm saying i know how to deal
with it
it's helping me deal with a lot of
things
i've had a lot of things happen to me in
my life a lot of tragedies that i have
dealt with my sister being killed in
front of me
that was one of them
you know i have to deal with that i have
to forgive myself for that happening
and i came to grips that it wasn't my
fault
and i couldn't have
known that he was going to do that
you know what i'm saying what he did
that day too
which was kill my sister
in broad daylight
on western in sloshing
he came out there to kill me
and she died for me
and i loved her forever for that i just
got a recent tattoo with her name on
there carrie
for my hand
how was she she was 30 years old when
that happened
uh
i'm
i'm just trying to be there for
everybody
that i can and i'm trying to be there
for me too um my niece who was growing
up without her mother now
because of
a senseless act of violence domestic
violence
you know what i'm saying took her mother
away from here and
i'm just trying to help her grow into
the woman that she's going to be a good
girl
she doesn't like anybody looking at her
body she doesn't like you know she she's
very well preserved
and um
she's gonna be all right
shout outs to nevada
that's my baby that's my my niecey fool
i love her
and they got sequoia that's my niece too
she's a
entrepreneur she's 18. and she has
lashes
she
she has her own business she makes
lashes
um
eyelashes
my sister does amazing hair
she does hair
probably better than anybody i know
because my mama told her
that did you did she do your hair that
we're looking at right now um
you know what this is it's a wig
this is a quick fix
you know i like those quick fixes oh wow
i like a quick fix so this is one of
your sisters and your wigs
huh
you guys are amazing here we are
that looks like real hair it does it's
beautiful
it's one thing that i've learned how to
do which is
fix myself up i can spruce my i can
clean up very well
you wouldn't know what was going on in
the inside by looking at me on the
outside
is this the roughest patch of your life
right now
um this is
this is
the best
yet is yet to come
like you know i feel like i have so much
more life ahead of me and i have so much
more to give and i want to encourage
people to
just
stay positive and and good will come to
you
you know and
going back to my we're talking about my
mother and her controlling ways she was
a controlling woman but she didn't have
no handbook on being a mother she didn't
have no instructions on being a mother
nobody told her what to do with her kids
she kept us in church and she
she did her best she could she always
did all she could for her kids she was
the best woman i know
and i didn't even know that she was
i looked just like her too
um
she was so beautiful and i didn't even
realize until she was already gone
she was already dead
i didn't realize how much i looked like
my mother
she was so awesome though she's the best
mother i could ever ask for
and she didn't have no teenage
pregnancies i didn't she didn't we
didn't have no bad times like
all i remember is the good times that we
all had
she raised some good kids
we all fall short of the glory we all we
all go astray but that isn't
it doesn't define who you are
people stereotype us every day
prostitution
i'm just a pro at what i do come on now
it's not a bad thing
i took the easy road i chose the easy
road okay
but i had housing i had section 8
my mother left it to me
okay
i just wasn't ready to get it when i got
it
and
and i didn't know how to i took it for
granted and a lot of things i took for
granted in my life and i would never do
it again
if i had a chance to do it all over
again
i would listen to the things that she
told me
when she told me what she told me
she said
if my mother if somebody asked to move
in her house she would not let them come
period you ain't on that lease you ain't
getting in
so
these are the do's and don'ts
you know that's what
that's why i'm out of my housing now
because
i let some guy that didn't even want me
to have housing you know didn't even
want me to have nothing else but him
control me and and
ultimately he was
out to kill me he wanted to kill me you
understand what i was saying he killed
my sister
so
that's how i lost my housing i did have
housing i had section eight
and uh what is section eight section
eight is uh subsidized housing for
low-income families
who can't afford their rent they have
paid some of your rent for you to keep
you housed
keep family's house in america
you had it and i had it but you lost it
too i lost it because this guy
was he didn't want me to have it he
didn't let me take care of none of my
business
he didn't want me to pay my rent he was
so happy when i lost it
he packed up all my [ __ ] and moved it
right to his house immediately
if i could do it all over again the day
he walked up to me and said do you need
help with your car
i just should have said no
i'm going to go to a mechanic
i don't want you working underneath my
hood
if he the first time he hit me if i
would have left
i would still have my sister here today
if i've never made an excuse for why he
hit me
most better women do you make excuses
for the reason why he oh he hit me
because i was doing it's no reason why
god should hit you
the first time he hits you you should
leave
period
period
i know so many women that i've
interviewed
maybe you've seen me on my channel who
i'm laughing but it's not a laughing
matter
who just keep running back to the same
guy who beats gives him they make
excuses for less better woman's knocking
her teeth out blackouts
syndrome yeah i made excuses for guys
too and i'll never make an excuse never
again
the first time a mother a guy hits me
he has to go you can say [ __ ] he
has to go he just has to go the first
time that mostly
seriously he has to go
nobody should have to be hit for
anything if i can't hit you for
everything you say to me then you
shouldn't be able to hit me shouldn't be
nothing that makes the person put their
hands on you great you can you can hit a
[ __ ] with your words
you can cut them with your your tongue
is your sword
okay
it's your sword that's the lethal weapon
that you have it's your tongue
you can hurt a [ __ ] with your
tongue
maybe
you can caress a person with your tongue
too
it works both ways yes it does
but uh
yes we didn't she was a good mother she
was awesome
um
you like your mom your personality
i mean you look like her but is your
personality like hers
you seem like the black sheep of your
family
um i was i am
i am
and i made myself the black sheep
because i don't have to be the black
sheep
everybody loves me they all love me
they all want me to be there but i was
punishing myself for my sister's death
i thought it was all my fault
and i've been living with that for the
past two years
that's what's kept me away from
everybody i stayed away from everyone
because of that i put it that was my
punishment for her dying and your
boyfriend who shot her is where he's in
jail he's doing 32 years
for killing my sister and trying to kill
me
i had to get justice for her
and i did it
i didn't want to
i it wasn't that i didn't want to it was
just that
i felt like
it was all my
fault so
i procrastinated
but
god wouldn't let it happen god wanted
me to do what i did
and i wanted it to because i know my
sister would do the same thing what were
the details why was he trying to shoot
you he was trying to shoot me because i
wouldn't go home
senseless it was just you can't make
someone do something that they don't
want to do
i told him i said if i come home on my
own it'll be better
just let me come on my own
and he didn't want he wanted to force me
and he came out there with a gun to
force
me he came to kill me
i'm a victim of domestic violence
my sister was a victim of domestic
violence i tragically lost her because
of domestic violence
she was my wing girl
she was she was about everything
she was not everything
but she couldn't live in my god is my
everything
you know
i just i just
in the second that he pointed that gun
at me that day
after he shot my sister and he pointed
the gun at me
i said i begged for my life you know
when i should have been doing what my
mother said
my mother said when you don't know what
to do call on the lord
and i should have been calling on god
begging god for my life but i was
begging this human
that couldn't even do he didn't care
what i was going to say that day he was
going to kill me
i begged him i said please tyrone you
don't have to do this please don't do
this and he said
[ __ ] the next one is for you
and he pointed that gun at me i looked
down at my sister
and she said
go get help
and i forgot everything that he was
doing and i ran past him and i ran in
the middle of the street to go get help
for my sister
you know so that changed my whole life
that's why i became addicted to the
streets
okay
that was my punishment
for my sister's death that i felt
responsible for
i knew it was all my fault
but it wasn't
because i couldn't control anything that
happened that day
god allowed that to happen
because i was shot in the same spot she
was shot at
same spot
he was shot in the i got shot that's
where my sister was shot at
and god allowed me to live
and he allowed her to die
you know you got to be careful what you
asked god for
you guys shot another time just to be
clear yes just recently yes i just was
shot recent on october the 30th the day
before halloween i was shot but my
sister was shot
two years prior to that three years
prior to that
her life was taken away from her
by my boyfriend
and
i was punishing myself for that by
staying in the streets staying away from
my family
when really i should have been closer to
my family
and maybe a lot of things that we went
through that i go that i went through i
didn't have to go through those things
but they happen and you live and you
learn
so i've learned from those mistakes
that's what i learned from my mistakes
learned
i won't make those same mistakes again
now i just want to help people
i truly and genuinely want to help
people
okay i want my sister name not to go
if i could tell a thousand girls
a million girls today that the second a
guy hits them
they should leave
they should just leave
don't make no excuse for no man get the
[ __ ] up out of there
period take your kids take whatever you
can take and get on
you'll thank yourself a whole you you
feel a whole lot
a like you have much more life like
life is worth living
okay
and she had her whole life ahead of her
and she didn't deserve to die like that
so
i just
i i personally i want to start a a
non-profit organization
in the name of kerry marie trotter
who died for me her sister
and
i want to want to help girls who are in
the same situation that i was in
i want them to get temporary shelter
temporary housing
and uh
i just want to mentor them
and tell them that everything is going
to be okay there is a light at the end
of the tunnel
you know
tell me about your father
tell me who your father my father
my father was an awesome guy he was
he was
he could sell salt to a slug
he was a hustler
he had no high school diplomas he had no
degrees
but he was a he was there for us he was
always there he had nothing but time for
his kids
nothing but time for us
he's always there he didn't have much
money but he had time
and i loved him too
he looked just alive he and your mom had
a good relationship
yes hey you know what you know what
he never hit her
she hit him
it was the other way around
my mom wouldn't let no man hit her
that's why i couldn't understand why i
let a man hit me because my mama i
didn't i didn't learn that from my mama
i never watched my mama get beat by no
man
i don't know why i accepted that
but i won't accept it ever again
the next man i fall in love with is
gonna be a big huge teddy bear he's
gonna be mean to everybody else and nice
to me
you deserve it i do
that and
much more
all right amber thank you for coming
back thank you so much for having me
stay out of those casitas
i'll stay in them because i like drama
you like drama i like trauma it's the
place to find it so what
kill me because i like drama
hey i like it you're like
so we we need a little drama everybody
needs drama
well now it makes you i like [ __ ]
just don't [ __ ] me
all right y'all thank you love you mark
i love you amber